this is one of the biggest revelations  about the january 6 riots it's really  incredible work by hunter walker who  researched and wrote this piece for  rolling stone pardons dangled  people who we already believed were  involved or admit to have been  coordinating events that day with the  white house allegedly doing far more  than that  and  it it's you know  all of these folks  are playing their roles the goes-r  pardon  never trust a promise or an intimation  from these people especially if they're  asking you to do something they wouldn't  do which goes-r had no interest in going  to this thing but gosar was certainly  interested in encouraging others by  dangling a pardon which never came  trump trump told his supporters let's go  to the capitol right now he went and  then watched on tv but he said we're  going down pennsylvania avenue  this story this explosive story  was nowhere on fox news this morning